welcome to this video against laboratory
all from Spain two wins zero losses
that's good I always feel a bit of ya
when I see this kind of statistic it
always feels like this sir good run is
going to end ok so this laugh line yeah
recently I got into some issues with
that when they play for a quickie 5 and
I didn't really have a good recipe
against that quince is seven and e5
proved to be problematic yeah that is
that I had before but always thought
that this should be quite ok for what I
have a good central pawn mattheum and
it's not easy to to play for him okay
just checking this pawn them if i go
night see for you can take on c3 maybe
maybe you can mesc 23 now I can do this
hmm
okay I can do this move though Queen c3
rugby one it's not really not really
possible okay yeah I'm not sure about
the move nights you for it looks
attractive and I think you cannot take
on c3 Red Queen a6 is kind of putting me
in a pin which looks a bit awkward that
looks a bit awkward where do I want my
bishop anyway only three probably right
tackle to be three Quincy three should
be two Quincy to air looks looks really
really awful put the Queen down
yeah I don't see a way to trap it though
yeah I really don't he takes you three I
don't really know Bishop d2 is I'm not
sure if the queen is strapped a bit of a
gamble yeah he didn't he didn't dare to
take it ok so we should be three that
was the point putting this now on III if
he goes c5 I have to be one for a good
position ok is he going for c5 maybe
mammoth that's not really doing that
much
hmm
yeah taking too long here look see one
way my daughter almost two minutes am
now I'm never super quick there but in
those early morning sessions I feel I'm
even slower mm-hmm so here from before
is you're just going to take it maybe
but it's hard to play without that move
if he gets a night be 62 a form so i
have to go f1 and ce4 will be a
liability so it's some no big big issue
okay now before I mean he always has to
worry about c4 pawn hmm I wonder get one
before takes the c3 yeah I don't like it
to go into this diagonal here it's a bit
of an ugly move but it's standing in
this sorry in this in this some in this
Fork is also not very nice threatening
night see for now night on a4 is a
liability one minute thirty ok now i can
take with the bishop
maybe you can check with the night then
we'll take everything off take stinks
okay let's let's play 93 maybe can play
nazi three Queens BBC three Quincy
frequent vanity fun we should be six so
i have to go here now c4 is hanging you
have to control before and it's a very
very tricky position not sure if I just
win c4 or not probably not and then this
isn't so great and this is a key a key
move ender and a problem time money
anyway let's go for that yeah my king
position is a bit shaky also i wonder if
he should keep Queens on the board mmm
like with Queen to be six or so the
Queen trade is not a big problem for him
either but it looks a bit with more
dangerous to keep the Queen's on the
board let's see five is my idea
ok so he was attacking f3 so let's cover
that
and not sure if you will actually trade
know how many I could have taken e6
anyway it's a bit risky but what can you
do I did not see that move coming
40 seconds runs into Bishop H form now
it's not easy to play really not against
the bishop am how do I do that rook
tutitu maybe and then go from them
check I can take you can take it did not
really see that coming check check I'm
actually ahead on the clock I wasn't
really aware of that then I would have
played a bit differently yeah is it
wrong it is a draw and he knows how to
how to get it DRA offered DRA offered
games yeah that it's a draw just a
positional draw so nothing I can do here
this is a useful thing to know if you
have those two points here it looks nice
of course here for I have to entering
some other thing no I have it sorry it's
ok so the problem is that i cannot win
here because he is looking at this at
five square with the king and the bishop
and whenever i play at five ok now it's
a smooth he has to stay on that diagonal
whenever i go life is of course just
going to Jack sacrifices bishop and I
have no way to improve on that I would
need a king let's say on e5 so that and
after f5 Bishop cake g takes i maintain
the Parliament I cannot ever go to e5 or
to e4 as then if I just go over there my
porn is hanging so there's no way
forward here for widen if I go air g5 is
just having this blockade on Fi forever
and ever so this is the problem this
position here for item this is a win but
I have to avoid them opposite connect
bishops I actually was still thinking
I'm down on time and that one can't play
it as simply as possible but that was
not the case it was about equal ish so I
could have tried him to play something
more
yeah ambitious the candy good thing
about 95 is in that that it eases the
play it's easier to play now yeah okay
with a tricky tricky game here it was I
don't know I didn't didn't like my
position very much I think one critical
moment was a for which he may be can
take now that that's an interesting
interesting moment I was thinking Queen
a 296 and possibly Bishop f1 but I'm not
threatening to take that any way or rook
be one that was my kind of idea with
that also maybe push d5 here on that
night that's really not clear at all
maybe he should have done that here okay
yeah Quincy to as I kind of an ugly move
but oh yeah and it gets punished if he
sees that one I am nice no my bishop
cannot run away now and I don't want
night text is free to happen not so much
because of the bishop pair but also
because of my very much week dark
squares yeah that would would be very
nice for black I constantly missed I
really constantly missed the idea to
play Bishop f4 him that would have been
would have been nice actually to trade
the dark squared Bishop snow I
completely missed the idea wasn't on my
radar I was completely fixed on this
kind of thing yeah yeah it's an
interesting situation and i'm totally
not sure what what to make of it I mean
black should be okay I'm just not sure
if I'm worse or not computer gives equal
and cakes and now it wants to play rook
c8 interesting not that
yeah it's a pawn but he has some a
decent decent compensation with the two
bishops maybe yeah it's starting to look
a bit strange em I should have maybe
gone for g4 immediately maybe that was a
little bit a little bit more precise if
we have the same thing we are starting
here when I got the second pawn it
should be there's really a lot better
for why they're probably should lead to
a wind with very good technical play but
I couldn't really do it in the time okay
well thanks for watching